in this video let us look at a certain
quantity of interest that has to do with
absorbing states now that we know how to
calculate the probability of getting to
a given absorbing state we would like to
know how long it would take to get to it
let us first deal with that question
when we have only one absorbing state
let us consider the following Markov
chain which is a little simpler than the
one that we had in the previous video we
have transient State
1 2 & 3 are transient State and we have
one recurrent State for and that way
current state 4 is an absorbing State
because once you get to it
you stay there forever so in this simple
example the absorption probability to 4
is trivially 1 no matter where you start
with priority 1 you're guaranteed that
eventually you will reach 4 but the
question of interest is to know how long
would it take to get to 4 in other words
how many transition will you have to do
until you reach for of course we don't
know it is a random variable in fact
it's more than one random variable it
will depend probably on where you
started starting from to one of three or
four would lead to different random
variables we are going to be interested
in looking at their expectation or the
expected value of these random variables
more precisely let us define exactly
what we want to do which is to find the
expected number of transition that we're
going to call mu of I until reaching 4
which is our absorbing state given that
the initial state is i1 of these four
states first as a warm-up let's do some
quick calculation if you didn't have
this part here and instead we were
looking just at this portion here and
make this one disappear like this and
replace it by a loop of probability zero
point eight so now if you start from
state two with priority zero point two
you
we'll go to four or with rarities 0.8
you will remain in two and now you ask
yourself what is the number of trials do
you have to do until you reach four
well we know what it is this is a
geometric random variable with the
priority of success which is the success
being going to four of zero point two so
the expected number of trial starting
from two that you will have to go
through until you reach 4 will be 1 over
this probability so 1 over 0 point 2
which is 5 now that we have done this
quick calculation it should be clear
that if we go back to the previous
Markov chain that we had here the
expected time mu 2 would probably be
bigger than 5 since from to not only you
have the priority of going to 4 but you
might have some chance of travelling
there so probably the number of time
until you reach for will be bigger than
5 let us see well first of all if you
start at 4 the expected number
transition until reaching for will
obviously be 0 so here 4 equals 4 you
indeed get 0 what about for the others
well again this is what we would like to
calculate how we're going to do that
well the argument is going to be of the
same nature as the one that we used
before we are going to think in terms of
tree and consider possible options
starting from a given state so let's do
this calculation from 2 so you are 2 and
we're gonna build that tree here so you
are in state 2 what could happen next
well you can either transition to 4 with
the priority 0.2 or with a priority 0.8
you end up in one and you have done one
transition here right so plus one
transition so you are interested in
calculating mewtwo after one transition
you either end up in 4 in that case you
stop you're done right in other words
resulting value here would be mu for
which we know is zero or you are in one
and now given that you are in one you
want to find the expected number of
transition until reaching for which is
exactly defined here so here what you
have is mu1 and now you can use the
troll expectation theorem to put all
these things together which what it
means is that mu 2 will be 1 you have
one transition and then after you do
that transition with protease you point
to you know that you're going to be in 4
and the expected value then will be mu 4
plus 0.8 which is the priority that you
end up in state 1 and conditioned on
that the remaining expected iterations
until reaching 4 will be mu 1 this one
is of course 0-3 what you end up is is 1
plus 0 point 8 mu 1 so you get a
relation between mu-2 and mu-1 now you
can do the same thing if you start from
1 or start from 3 so let's do it again
from 1 so you're interested in one after
one transition so plus 1 what happened
well with the probability is 0.6 you end
up in two and whether it is 0.4 you end
up in 3 and from 3 if you start in state
3 after one transition what happened
well with the probability is 0.5 you
would end up in state 1 and then the X
number expected number transition from
state 1 and you're reaching for it will
be mu 1 all without is 0.5 you end up in
2
so again here if you look at these three
here this is a system of three equations
three linear equations with three
unknown and it has a unique solution I
will let you do the calculation let me
give you the result what you obtain is
mu1 will be 110 over 8 and the reason
I'm writing it this way so that we can
compare them mewtwo will be 96 over 8
which is 12 and mu3 is 111 over 8 so
here again a quick sanity check the
number that we get here 12 is indeed
bigger than the 5 that we have obtained
when we restricted ourselves to this set
so we do have mu2 greater than 5 now as
the relative value between mu1 mu2 and
mu3 it's sort of make sense mu2 the
state 2 is the one closest to 4 is 1
actually link to 4 so in some sense the
expected number of transition to reach 4
will always be the smallest one because
starting from the other states you will
have to go to 2 before going to 4 and in
general if you have a general Markov
chain with transient state and 1
absorbing state and you are asking
yourself what is the expected time to
absorption to that unique absorbing
state it will be the unique solution
from the system of equation given here
where the pIJ are the transition
probabilities of your markov chain now
we have seen how to solve this problem
when we have one unique absorbing state
what happen if you have more than one
absorbing state like for example in this
case well first of all a quick note
you realize here that you have 1 2 & 3 3
transient States and indeed here you
have 4 as an absorbing state it's a
recurrent State and once you get to it
you get you stay
forever and five is also a recurrent
State and once you get to five you stay
there forever right
so four and five are both absorbing
states and in a previous video we had
seen how to calculate the probability of
adding up in four as opposed to ending
up in five what we know is that the
priority of ending up in four plus the
virtue of ending up in five will be one
but since the priority of adding up in
four is not one trying to find the
expected number of steps until you reach
for specifically does not make much
sense that expectation of that random
variable is a random variable
but that expectation will be infinity
why because there is a positive
probability that you will end up in five
and if you add up in five once you get
there the number of steps to go to four
well the infinity so it makes more sense
to think about what is the expected time
to any absorbing state so to either four
or five now if you are interested in
that quantity one trick in order to
solve that problem using the technique
that we have seen so far is to combine
four and five into one mega state call
it whatever six right and six is a
combination of four and five it's a big
absorbing state and once you're in six
you stay in six and now you just have to
define exactly what is the probability
of transition from one two and three to
that mega state well here from two you
had originally two arcs you're gonna
combine these two into one arc and
you're gonna sum this probability so you
had zero point three and zero point two
you put on here 0.5 and on this arc you
had only one arc so you maintain that
arc and you have that probability that
you had which was I believe 0.32 now you
go back if you look at the situation now
it's very close to the one that we had
here all right see if these four that
you have here
hd6 now of course you have another arc
here like that but that's fine you can
still add the arc here and put it at 0.2
and then you reduce this one to 0.3 to
make it square and here but the idea on
how to solve that is identical to this
one you would have to change a little
bit of this but this is the same
technique so Indian we have seen a
technique to find the expected time to
absorptions whenever you have absorbing
states in an even Markov chain